first up the government has promised to
invest hundreds of millions of pounds in
low-carbon technologies as part of its
net zero strategy but critics have
warned it won't cover the cost of the
green transition and consumers will end
up footing the bill it raises questions
about how the costs should be shared out
between the government taxpayers and
businesses so who should pay for net
zero tom to you first we know that there
are big changes that need to be made in
order to move towards net zero this week
the focus has been on on that of of heat
pumps across to consumers as well as
government but whose responsibility
ultimately is it to foot these massive
bills
well in some sense it's all of our
responsibility because it's all of us
who are creating the problem but how we
pay is very much a question whether
governments uh how government which
policies they choose
for distributing those costs and if
governments choose to ban policies then
the cost will fall unfairly on the
people who can least afford it but if it
chooses the right policies then what
we'll be doing is making sure that um
pays some of it consumers pay some of it
business pays some of it and that's a
question therefore of how the government
chooses to set up policy framework so
that we can all respond in a way that's
appropriate to our own particular
circumstances and of course our own
means so how we pay for it michaela but
also when the timing of when we deal
with these bills do we need to pay for
it now
or can we leave it to future generations
so i think i also kind of want to go
back to the question of like who is
responsible because i think too often
we make this too broad we say that we
are responsible for the climate crisis
of humanity is when in reality when 100
companies responsible for 71 of
greenhouse gas emissions since 1988
there are particular people a very small
group of people and companies and
systems that are responsible for this
problem and therefore i think that it's
important that we kind of zoom out on
that a bit more and stop making about
like all individuals who many of whom
are marginalized and instead make it
about these industries and these
businesses and that's why i think that
these businesses and especially the
fossil fuel industry should be paying
now um currently the uk government gives
huge amounts of subsidies to this
industry so in the north sea since 2016
the uk government has given four billion
pounds of public money to this industry
and hasn't been a lot of these companies
have been paying tax so imagine if
instead these companies are being taxed
well now and they are the ones who
caused the crisis if they were instead
being the ones funding the transition
and i think that they could do that and
they should be doing that now
and tom have we got political consensus
on this on how and when we pay
no we we haven't got political consensus
on how there are some people who think
we can delay uh some people politically
think we can somehow put off uh delaying
paying for this and for government
paying the party it needs to pay uh in
playing and that's that's kind of really
very silly at the end of the day you
know
i listened to the chancellor the other
day talk about his reluctance to borrow
more money because it would impose costs
on uh our children well if he's not
prepared to borrow the money to invest
in uh on uh uh doing the damage we're
doing to the climate then he certainly
will be making our children pay but they
won't be paying him money they'll be
paying a very damaged uh lives so i
think it's really important for
government to play its part and
michaela's quite right it's very
important that uh business is based and
she was absolutely right to point out
the fact there's something completely
silly by paying fossil fuel companies
subsidies at the same time as you're
trying to get other people to pay in
order to undo the damage being done by
those subsidies
mikayla i can see you nodding along with
tom on that
yeah absolutely i think that it is
completely outrageous that this
government that says they have no magic
money tree or that they don't have the
money to fund the climate um the just
transition that we need are then paying
loads of public money to north sea oil
and gas companies who are multi billion
pound companies that don't need this
money and that are actually laying off
so many workers in the north sea
currently and are trying to expand into
new oil fields they're just being
promoted and polluting and it's
completely ridiculous and especially
when like my generation the younger
generation are going to be the ones
putting the bills for the
decommissioning costs of these rigs that
are being built now it just feels
completely ludicrous and i think that
when we're talking about like who should
be paying we need to be making sure that
it's the people who have caused this
crisis
you